let's bring in pat 40 sports illustrated
senior writer here
you're usually the one uh the bearer of
bad news but i beat you to the punch
here
uh 15 minutes ago here pat so just to
recap
we got the big ten and pac-12 they are
scheduled to cancel
uh fall sports coming up tomorrow you
have the
big 12 and you have the acc on the fence
and the sec is looking at tv contracts
see if they can maybe bring in some
schools so what has happened what has
changed since last week here
well a few things changed i mean only in
college sports dan is it possible
that you're releasing schedules all last
week getting people excited
and then on saturday morning basically
northern illinois goes into a meeting
and the mid-american conference says
we're not playing
and all of a sudden everybody's like oh
if you're not going to play
maybe we shouldn't play and then the
mid-american conference the number nine
or ten conference in the nation
says we're not gonna play and nobody
else is like oh i guess we're not gonna
play either
it's i mean it's unbelievable that this
could happen in the space of a weekend
now
i think the big ten was tracking that
way all along or certainly for the last
week even before that kevin warren the
commissioner has been the most cautious
and guarded of all the power five
commissioners talking about the season
i think the winds were blowing that way
strongly during the week the
mid-american conference probably stuck a
finger in the air and said if the big
ten's going
well we're probably going to go first
yeah it felt like
that you got the uh commissioners
together that they wanted to be
all in on this and not have you know
an outlier and the sec may be that
outlier but we thought that that was a
possibility anyway the last couple of
months here
i know that the pac-12 didn't want to be
the first to announce this then i think
the big ten was maybe going to take that
pre-emptive strike and say all right
we'll be the ones to announce it and
then the pac-12 i don't know what
happens with the acc in the big 12. but
could you see where
the sec goes alone and says
we're going to play x number of games
here and have a conference champion and
we'll have a mythical national champion
i think it'd be highly improbable you
know we reported last night and really
over the weekend that
by the end of this week everybody will
be out and there will be no fall
football
uh you know i think that i think the big
12 is
closer to going the way of the big ten
and pac-12 than most people think
the acc is more closely in line with
where the sec is but i think ultimately
they all realize
we're not going to play uh there may
still be some people pushing for it in
the sec
but here's why you can't really be the
outlier and go it alone first of all
if all the other conferences with all of
their medical experts
and all their presidents say we don't
think it is safe for the players
is the sec supposed to say we really
don't care whether today for the players
we're going
because we like football i don't think
that's going to happen and the other
thing is
a lot of the state schools in that
league have pushed really hard at the
presidential level
to enhance the academic profiles of
their schools specifically florida
georgia alabama
mississippi and south carolina they want
out-of-state tuition dollars by making
the school a better place
if you say we're a football power and we
want to play football we don't care
about the pandemic that's not going to
help you
at admissions time how does this affect
these
uh players who would be eligible for the
nfl draft if if you think about it
these one-year wonders that we've had
recently you know
dwayne haskins where would joe burrow be
uh kyler murray
these guys who and you know i'm talking
about just quarterbacks but there are a
lot of positions here
there are a lot of players who came out
of nowhere joe burrell was a fifth round
draft pick
and then he had the magical season and
is the number one pick overall dwayne
haskins comes out of nowhere
kyler murray out of baseball um
now what do they do i don't know i mean
that's it's tough for those guys you
feel bad
look i feel bad for all the players and
it's been amazing to watch you know
tyler or trevor lawrence basically
unionized college football at midnight
last night
you know uh these guys they want to play
a lot of them do
and yeah for the for the established
stars who aren't going to play because
they're not there's no way they're
playing in the spring
to the up and coming guys to the hidden
gems that you were talking about
this takes away a big opportunity for
them and yeah you can try to play in the
spring
sure and some guys would be happy to
play and try to help improve their stock
then but this is i mean it puts a major
crimp in the entire trickle down
of football from the nfl through college
to high school recruiting
everything is on hold and up in the air
what do you think happens today
uh you know i don't know whether if you
know if the big ten will wait until
tomorrow
on this uh there's a scheduled meeting
uh for pac-12 presidents tomorrow
or if something happens today uh you
know i'm not sure
i i would expect as you as you obviously
said those two are going to be
probably first i do think the big ten
was trying to get everybody on the same
page since everybody was mad at the big
ten in july
for preempting everyone on the schedule
they were all supposed to be on the same
page then
uh but i think the other conferences too
are going to be right there
behind them as far as the the group of
five leagues uh
you know today here's what i think today
the players will continue to make a
social media push to try to make their
voices heard to say hey
let's reconsider and good for them but
it's not going to be enough
yeah i was told liability that was the
key word that liability with these
universities
and if something happens and you know
what it would cost them you know the
risk and the reward
uh the risk isn't worth the reward but
can you make a case though pat
that at these power five conferences who
do have the money to test
and and you know unlike the mid-american
conference that
they are safer on campus than maybe they
would be if they were
at home and uh you know socializing sure
well i mean here's the thing i mean the
players should
will probably stay on campus i mean
unless these campuses are going to close
down to students most of them are having
students on campus not all of them
but most of them so you know i i don't
anticipate
the ohio state team and the michigan
team going home per se
i think they will stay there unless they
want to opt out and work out for the
draft
so you know i think you'll stay there
and you'll still be in a situation where
you're probably getting
uh routine testing and you're working
out there and they're trying to make
things as safe as possible
i think another big factor dan is
worry about heart conditions there has
been a few players here and there who
have said hey
my heart is not right uh there have been
doctors who have said they've got that
some players have had enlarged hearts
myocytis
and that really got the attention the
presidents my colleague ross dellinger
did a good story on that just that
when you start talking to presidents
about unknown long-term heart damage and
you to your point of liability do you
want to be on the hook
if you got five players with heart
damage yeah you bring that
up and and i was told that uh they're
seeing players if they
maybe asymptomatic but a couple of weeks
after the fact they're starting to see
some issues with their hearts with some
of these players
granted it might be a small sample here
but these are things that
you know a university is liable and they
realize this that
just you know what would happen with
lawsuits here if something happened
so i think that's why they're you know i
think they were in denial for a long
time
and i just think that now as we get
closer to
classes starting and kids coming on
campus
the reality hit home yeah now that they
pushed the decision so far down the road
as far as they could
and we're in denial like hey we can pull
this off can't we sure we can let's put
on a show and you know
the closer you get to it the more
there's just too many problems
facing it and now you know we'll see if
they can get together and come up with a
plan for the spring there's no good
spring options but is there a spring
option that's close enough to good that
you can do
or have they just been sitting there
with wishful thinking about the fall and
not even thought about the spring yet
yeah if you could interview one person
on the record
involved in all of this who would you
want to interview
coach player i think i would interview
probably gene smith at ohio state the
athletic director there because i
you know they're the flagship program of
that conference
and i think he's a smart man and they've
got
a great season ahead but they're not
they're putting on the brakes on this
and i want to know
what exactly are the concerns from a
health standpoint that have made you
want to stop an incredibly good season
at a place that cares incredibly much
about college football yeah that's the
surprising element here when i told you
that there were two schools in the big
ten that were pushing to play
you probably would have thought ohio
state for sure and now i find out that
it's
uh nebraska and it's iowa does that
surprise you at all
nebraska doesn't surprise me at all the
second one i from inklings i had gotten
it wasn't going to be ohio state i
thought maybe purdue
because mitch daniels the president
there former governor of indiana
has been pretty bullish on trying to
let's reopen let's
normalize so i wouldn't have guessed
iowa but nebraska yeah
good to talk to you again pat thanks for
joining us as always great great work
over the weekend
thank you optimism 2021 pat 40
sports illustrated senior writer